did you have trouble crossing under this
bridge in chapter two
well here's a trick that allows any
build to get across kick spamming this
technique is useful in so many
situations I think this is by far the
most energy efficient way to cover
distance in armored Core 6. it can save
you if you're about to fall off a stage
it can get you across vast distances it
can get you higher than you'd otherwise
be able to go so definitely consider
this especially if you're equipped with
tank treads I think bear kick gets you
the furthest
speaking of kicks you might have noticed
that kicks don't just do impact damage
they deal direct damage as well and
while you might think that leg type
would play a part in direct damage or
impact dealt it doesn't however the
direct damage of your kick is affected
by something it's affected by the weight
of your AC for example this is a kick
with a lightweight AC and here's a kick
with the heaviest tank I could make
what's also interesting is that kicks do
roughly three times as much damage to
enemies when they're staggered which is
a much bigger multiplier than most other
weapons have combine this with the fact
that you can spam kicks pretty fast this
can be a really lethal tool especially
if you have nothing else to do while
reloading and on some enemies like
tetrapod MTS you can extend the duration
of their stagger if you kick them during
this state so if you haven't worked
kicks into your playstyle yet absolutely
do that thank you but let's be honest
more important than anything else in
this video is your fashion your armor
Decor so to speak and one key part of
your fashion is your booster color
because did you notice that booster
color isn't determined by the booster
part instead it's actually determined by
your generator for example this
generator gives me a blue booster which
actually turns my gold AC like an ugly
green this one gives a nice default
orange which is better but this Coral
generator gives me this awesome red
color and even though it has a recharge
delay of like five seconds you know I'm
still gonna use it speaking of fashion
though this is my LG Corporation AC and
I made this because LG are actually our
corporate sponsor for this video so I
wanted to do a video with LG because
uniquely among from software games
armored Core 6 actually has amazing
widescreen support So LG sent over one
of their ultrawides for me to show you
guys and I was absolutely blown away
this I think is unironically the best
way to play Armored Core in my opinion
the curved screen just makes this game
so immersive and having a wide field of
view is legitimately incredible for your
situational awareness because you can
see all of the enemies around you while
you're fighting so this is the LG Ultra
gear OLED 45 gr
95qe sounds like it could be a part in
game it's a 45 inch 21x9 display with a
clean really borderless design and also
a crazy fast
0.03 millisecond response time which
makes it perfect for gaming they're also
touting this as the world's first 240
hertz OLED gaming monitor if you're
interested in investing in one for
yourself check out the link in the
description and thank you to LG for
sponsoring this video number five if you
ever run out of energy in the air you
are extremely vulnerable you can't Dodge
or fly all you can do is fall but did
you know that falling directly down is
actually the best thing you can do in
this situation a lot of the time when
you push forward on the left analog
stick as long as your boosters are
toggled on you'll still float somewhat
horizontally even when you're completely
out of energy note our speed while we're
doing this however if you let go of the
left stick completely your boosters will
deactivate and you'll enter free fall
mode in this state you'll fall a lot
faster even though it says your boosters
are still on just look at the speed
difference therefore Free Falling
straight down can actually make you way
more avoidant of projectiles coming your
way especially if you're falling
perpendicular to the shot that's coming
your way so consider doing this as a
last resort next time you run out of
energy in the air number six so Target
assist can be great it gives you
unparalleled focus on single enemies and
it makes it way easier for you to focus
on dodging and flying but it's actually
not the optimal way to play that's
because when you toggle on target assist
your tracking strength is actually
compromised and less of your shots will
find their Mark as a result this is
absolutely something you can feel in the
gameplay and you might have even noticed
how much more your reticle lags behind
when you're locked on in this way but
the question is how bad is this effect
how much is your tracking strength
compromised when using Target assist
let's try to figure it out so there are
a lot of variables that make this really
hard to test in a vacuum we have to
ensure that our enemy is moving in
pretty much the exact same way at the
exact same speed at the exact same
distance with Target assist toggled on
and then off so I came up with this the
jump test with this distance and
movement become controlled variables and
we can really try to narrow down the
difference in accuracy with Target
assist toggled on and off here's what I
found so at 50 meters with Target assist
off
0.018 percent of my shots missed
compared to 12 percent of my shots
missing with Target assist at 100 meters
with Target assist off 27 of my shots
missed compared to 47 with Target assist
and at 150 meters with Target assist off
it was 44 compared to 61 with Target
assist and and then at 200 meters 55 of
my shots missed without it and 74 missed
with Target assist so just at a glance
from that data Target assist is clearly
having a big impact here in many cases
almost twice as many of my shots missed
while using Target assist
now admittedly I didn't get like a huge
sample size here and I only tested this
with one weapon so I'd really like to
invite someone better than me to perform
the jump test more thoroughly if I find
someone who does a really good
experiment online I'll pin their results
in the comments section below but for
now I think it's safe to say that you
really should be trying to learn to play
without Target assist if you can
especially if your enemy is small and
agile for number seven let's talk about
these gaps so often advice I give when
building an AC is to try and stay as
close to your maximum loads as possible
this will ensure that you're packing on
the most value that your legs and
Generator can support that said there
are benefits to leaving gaps here that
you might not know about in regards to
your maximum load a larger Gap will
contribute towards your Boost speed so
notice how my Boost speed becomes faster
when I just unequip my weapons that's
because leftover load contributes to
your speed you can even achieve this
boost to your speed by purging weapons
during a mission what's interesting is
that a similar logic applies to your en
load as well the larger the Gap the
faster your energy bar will recharge
that's because leftover en output
contributes towards your supply
efficiency stat the higher this value
the faster your energy bar will move
after the recharge delay just look at
this difference
now it's really cool that the game
rewards your excess like this but I will
say in my experience the benefits of
having a large gap still don't really
outweigh the benefits of just stacking
on better Parts instead for example like
your energy is coming back fast either
way you know but it's a nice thing to
have for sure another thing that's
really nice to have is the hangar Bay
upgrade in your OS tuning screen this
allows you to store two more arm parts
on your back note however that you can't
fire these weapons when they're stored
in the hangar instead L1 and R1 will
just switch to these weapons for your
arms instead and when you first think
about it that seems kind of bad right
after all wouldn't you just want to fire
four weapons at once isn't that more DPS
than just two however consider this
weapons that overheat can cool down in
the hangar weapons can even reload while
they're in the hangar so just think
about how good that is with this
technique you can offset the downside of
some of the strongest weapons in the
game fire your chain guns to overheat
and then switch to shotguns while they
cool down in the hangar break guards
with the pal bunker melee weapon then
pull out a sword to capitalize on that
while it cools down or just equip four
machine guns and switch them out
whenever you need to reload this way
your DPS is absolutely unrelenting and I
unironically think after testing a lot
of this stuff that hanger builds will
end up being some of the strongest
builds in the game
anyway speaking of os upgrades do you
regret any of the OS upgrades you've
invested in well don't worry because by
pressing triangle or Y in this menu you
can undo each upgrade you've purchased
for 4 000 credits one reason I redid my
points is because I realized that the
most efficient way to invest your points
is actually to invest in the lowest tier
of many upgrades rather than going deep
into just one that's because the lowest
tiers are the cheapest so it's kind of
best to buy all the low tiers first
number 10. this next trick is
particularly good when you're fighting
an enemy AC though I'll admit it's a
pretty high skill cap thing to do and
that's melee canceling so by tapping
quick boost right at the end of your
melee boost you're able to cancel your
melee boost and immediately initiate it
again creating a loop where you're
constantly moving closing in on and
threatening the enemy AC without even
overheating your weapon this is
particularly good if you've chosen a
booster that has a really good melee
attack thrust and a melee attack en
consumption spec as these can enable you
to close the gap between enemies more
effectively than even an assault boost
could it also looks cool as hell that's
kind of the main reason to do this
honestly but the coolest thing you can
do in armored Core is s ranking missions
according to the game to achieve an S
rank rating you must complete the
mission without retrying from a
checkpoint while also minimizing
incoming damage time taken and
ammunition consumed in practice though
it's actually not that simple for
example in the mission destroy the
transport helicopters I finished the
objectives extremely fast without taking
a point of damage and only got an a-rank
to achieve an S rank I realized it
helped a lot to actually kill some
enemies as well the game doesn't tell
you that you need to kill enemies but
that is important apparently and then
for certain missions it seems like the
s-rank criteria are weighted differently
for example in a chapter 2 mission I
destroyed the smart cleaner very quickly
but I used dual Gatling guns to do it
and even though I didn't die I achieved
a really low rank for some reason for
this Mission it seems ammunition cost
counted against me greatly and then
there was this mission where I took a
ton of damage and I was sure that I did
terribly and then I got an S rank turns
out this Mission has an extremely high
tolerance for the damage you take so my
takeaway from all of this is that while
it's certainly possible to S rank by
focusing on just doing one thing well
there are missions where it feels like
some things matter more than most so
definitely try and switch up your build
and strategy if you're not having much
success build for Speed or kills or low
ammunition costs or low damage taken and
see how you go prioritizing different
things but what's the reward for S
ranking every mission in the game you
ask well it makes you feel good
according to my reviewer guide you get a
trophy and an achievement and that's it
which I'll admit is a little bit
disappointing I wish there was some
incentive but I guess it's more about
the journey in the end
one of the metrics for s-ranking
Missions is again not being wasteful
with your ammunition so you might think
that reloading manually and just
throwing away the entire rest of the
magazine would be wasteful right wrong
because video game laws are in effect
here and when you reload in armored Core
6 your magazine will magically fill with
the exact amount of ammunition you need
despite that kind of being physically
impossible that means that you only
really need to worry about the
ammunition that you fire in a mission
and nothing more being wasteful is a
pretty fast way to rack up some debt in
armored Core 6 though admittedly
incurring debt is quite rare even if
you're firing the most expensive
Weaponry this is the most debt I could
get when I tried for example I just
quickly wanted to confirm that yeah it
is possible to go negative in a mission
and lose money though no matter how much
you waste or lose it's impossible to
actually go negative in terms of your
total funds in the garage
speaking of firing ammunition there are
many situations where you might want to
consider staggering your fire rather
than unloading all at once for example
when fighting a fast opponent like an
enemy AC it's very likely that they'll
Dodge your attacks especially your
missiles so for example if you unload
two sets of missiles at them at once
they can just easily negate both of
those salvos with one Dodge instead what
you should do is fire one after the
other with a short delay this way you're
far more likely to catch them during or
after a Dodge with at least one set of
missiles the same applies to weapons
with a slow firing rate take dual
shotguns for example if I fire both at
once they're both liable to miss but if
I fire one after the other even if I
missed one the second is far more likely
to connect
spacing out your shots also makes it
less likely that enemies will get a
chance to recover their ACS buildup
which is what can happen if they go too
long without taking damage
next I believe that there are just two
status effects in armored Core 6. ACS
anomaly and electrical discharge however
the game doesn't really explain what
these are so I'll try ACS anomaly is
built up over time with fire-based
attacks when the bar fills completely
you'll receive this warning which lasts
for about 10 seconds during this time
the impact damage you receive is
significantly increased compare this for
example
this
and while we're looking at the stack
gauge it's important to note that the
middle bar is easier to fill up than the
outer bars essentially it seems like
this middle section counts as one bar
and filling the outer two bars takes
twice as long there are two bars on the
outside after all so effectively it
seems like ACS anomaly increases the
impact damage You Take by about 50 for
10 seconds which makes it really quite
an impactful status effect the other
status effect in ac6 is the shock status
effect which I figured out is
essentially bleed from other from soft
games basically what happens is when you
take electrical damage your elec
discharge bar will fill doing a burst of
damage once at the end when the bar is
completely filled what's interesting
about this shock effect in this game
though is that it's actually not
percentage-based damage unlike bleed
from previous
regardless of your AP this effect seems
to do a flat 1 600 damage meaning shock
will kind of naturally be better against
lightweight ACS rather than heavy ones
of course you can build up status
effects on other enemies as well even
non-ac enemies like MTS though it's
worth noting that clearly some enemies
have more resistance than others and
some bosses effectively seem immune to
status effects entirely
now there kind of is a third status
effect although it's strictly not one as
well it's the smoke bomb which has an
effect that creates a little bubble a
little Zone and while you're inside this
Zone you can't lock onto enemies outside
it and they can't lock onto you if
you're inside it either however if
you're both inside the Zone then you can
lock onto each other and if this smoke
is in between both of you it actually
acts like a piece of terrain wood it
blocks you from locking onto the enemy
at a distance as well essentially this
is really cool but as its description
States it's going to take a lot of
finesse to effectively use this in
combat if there are more status effects
in the game I haven't listed I apologize
I'm playing through the game really
thoroughly but I'm playing through
really slowly as well I've only just
finished chapter three so it's possible
that there's more that I'm missing
number 16 canceling this is only
mentioned very briefly in training so
remember pressing triangle or Y will
allow you to cancel certain actions for
example if you're charging a weapon and
no longer want to charge it just press
triangle or Y and if you've started a
multi-lock that you regret you can also
press triangle or Y to revert to a
single lock now I'm kind of shocked that
this next tip isn't in the official
tutorial and that's that in most
situations it's not optimal to cancel
your assault boost by pulling back on
the left stick like the tutorial tells
you to do doing this actually brings you
to an abrupt halt which can easily get
you killed instead by pushing forward on
the left stick and just tapping the
Ascend button we are able to cancel your
assault boost and maintain your forward
momentum which is just objectively
better number 18. so unlike in other
from soft games you can't actually load
multiple saves in the main menu you can
only have one playthrough active at any
time so be careful of that new game
button this time around since it will
overwrite your current save I can kind
of see why they made it this way the
game is designed around replaying
missions and going into New Game Plus
after all
one thing that oddly does seem to
persist if you start a new game is your
AC data from your previous save if you
didn't know in this menu you can quickly
build your old saved AC designs though
of course you still need their parts um
I'd also quickly like to mention that
you can upload your AC designs in this
menu as well this will give you a code
to share with others who might want to
create your AC here's the code for my LG
AC though this doesn't seem to work
cross-platform the same goes for emblem
designs while you're in the garage one
thing not many people realize you can do
is enter photo mode while you're here
here you can fly your camera around
quite far and explore the little
container that you're a stowaway within
and of course the same photo mode can be
activated while you're out on a mission
during the pause menu
another small thing but there are
situations where you really should use
the compass and the radar that's built
into it in this mission for example it's
important for me to head towards enemies
as soon as they appear and my radar is
the best way of doing that what's more
lots of information shows up down here
like Target objectives and more these
little arrows for example also indicate
if an enemy is above or below you in
that direction
if you're on your first attempt or don't
care at all about s ranking a mission
consider simply restarting from
checkpoints as soon as you notice that
you've reached one for example here I've
taken so much damage that there's just
no way I'm going to beat Sula in this
upcoming fight it would be a waste of my
time instead as soon as I notice this
indicator in the bottom right I can just
manually start from the checkpoint and
fully restore my AP and my repair kits
for number 22 remember that your
standard repair kit heals a flat 4000 AP
so when healing try to make sure that
you've taken 4000 damage before healing
it and when building an AC consider that
you functionally have 12 000 more AP
than what it's showing you on screen so
when you think about your functional AP
and keep healing in mind the difference
between a heavyweight AC with a lot of
AP and a lightweight AC with not much AP
P the difference between them gets
smaller when you take into account that
both builds have 12 000 AP on top of
what they already have that said repair
kits aren't a thing in the arena so I
think that heavy ACS really will benefit
from their raw AP and defensive stats a
lot more there
just one extra thing when you fall off
the map in armored Core 6 you don't take
a flat AP punishment instead falling off
the map will take 35 of your total AP
let's talk about some of the Lesser used
OS tuning upgrades one of the worst kind
of has to be access speed optimization
which increases your interaction speed
by 50 and then 100 this can be useful
but it's extremely situational for
example some missions might have you
hack something while you're in firing
range it's pretty good then so I
definitely consider this upgrade to be
great for S ranking certain missions but
other than that I'd rank it as a pretty
low priority one little secret you might
have missed with this though is that
objects have different scan levels
associated with them I've found three
scan levels so far and the higher that
their s dot LV is the longer they will
take to access another arguably less
important OS tuning upgrade is the quick
tone which when unlocked allows you to
do a 90 degree or a 180 degree turn of
your Mech and the camera by holding
Circle or B and turning your left stick
in the desired Direction in any other
armored Core game this would be
incredible but in armored Core 6 it's
kind of just all right the best thing
about it is that it moves your camera
faster than you can even with camera
speed set to 10. though those playing
with mouse and keyboard actually won't
have this problem at all it's worth
unlocking this if you play with the
controller and if you play without
Target assist but I feel like most
players can confidently give this one a
miss
another very Niche OS upgrade is weight
control which lets you enter missions
overweight and manually Purge your
weapons being over your weight limit
seems to penalize your speed in a
similar way to how being under your
weight limit rewards your speed so going
into a mission overweight really isn't
the worst thing in the world the best
use case I could think of for this would
be when you use it in tandem with its
manual Purge function this way you could
enter a mission with heavy Weaponry you
could use up those weapons and then you
could purge them if you no longer have a
use for them so the best use case I
could think of for that was to bring in
heavy snipers use them at a safe range
where your lack of speed doesn't really
matter then purge them and get in close
with your faster AC what's also cool is
that you'll get these weapons back after
you've purged them at a resupply station
so you will be able to have them back
for difficult boss encounters at the end
of the mission
and if you do go with this purging
strategy consider choosing an arm part
with a high melee specialization stat
this will increase the damage of your
punches but so far for me I haven't
really been able to build around Weight
Control in a meaningful way maybe later
in the game I'll unlock some parts that
make that viable so I'm curious if you
guys have any ideas for that but that's
it before I go again think about
investing in an ultra wide monitor for
your setup it's so good links in the
description thanks again to LG for
sponsoring this video Forget Balaam
forget archivists thank you LG
I'll see you all next time